sometimes the best comedic actors falter
on SNL while an athlete or musician can
prove surprisingly funny and people
you're certain will bomb find a way to
hold their own in celebration of one of
televisions great institutions here are
the best and worst hosts to ever step on
the SNL stage many people mistakenly
believe that Steve Martin was a cast
member on SNL that's both a testament to
the impact he's had on the show and an
indication of just how popular he is
with viewers Martin is the current
runner-up to Alec Baldwin as most
frequent hosts with 15 episodes to his
name plus countless cameo appearances
over the past four decades what's
perhaps most telling is how frequently
Martin appeared in the show's early
years he hosted for the first time on
October 23rd 1976 and in less than two
years he had already joined the
illustrious five timers Club mr. Steve
in those early days he originated the
characters that made him an SNL favorite
from King Tut and Theodoric of York -
one of the wild and crazy' fest drunk
brothers of course we can't forget his
very famous Christmas wish and one of
the show's great solo sketches sometimes
SNL books hosts who aren't professional
performers but are just having a
pop-culture moment that can be a recipe
for disaster
like when Donald Trump hosted in 2004
when The Apprentice was riding high and
then again in 2015 when he was in the
midst of campaigning for president
the result was predictably high ratings
but not very good comedy and the show's
cast wasn't particularly happy to have
Trump in the building former cast member
Taran Killam later described feeling
intense shame over the episode while
Pete Davison commented that Trump was
weird all week during rehearsals
regardless of how you feel about him as
president we can generally agree that
Donald Trump was not a great SNL host
Tom Hanks has hosted SNL nine times
since 1985 meaning he starred in classic
sketches in four separate decades
he's long distinguished himself as a
versatile performer equally adept at
dark dramas and screwball comedies in
the particular crucible of SNL he
somehow manages to show a different side
of himself again and again proving just
how good and how funny he really is time
after time
there's something very reassuring about
seeing Hanks on the SNL stage as
America's dad gets ready to goof off
with the kids for the night he's had
unforgettable chemistry with numerous
cast members and a wide variety of
sketches he's gotten huge laughs while
checking the levels on the mics as a
roadie for Aerosmith we're getting
everything as mr. short term memory and
donning a black and orange suit as David
s pumpkins everyone wants to know the
dirt on what happens behind the scenes
at SNL but the show has a reputation as
an inviting space for celebrities to
come in and try their hand at live
comedy so cast members can't necessarily
say anything bad about certain
celebrities while they're working on the
show that means that rude or unpleasant
behavior often evaporates into the ether
after hosts leaves but in some cases
cast members can't stop talking about a
disaster and that was the case with
Justin Bieber who served as both host
and musical guest in 2013 former SNL
star Bill Hader who's never been the
type to gossip about former hosts unless
they really deserved it called the
Bieber experience his worse than 8 years
on the show yeah in a bad place maybe
he's in a better place but that he
wasn't a very it was true
hater also noted that Bieber showed up
with a large entourage and was rude to
cast members but he was also sympathetic
with the then teenage superstars placed
in the world at the time he just he just
seemed like exhausted or the end of a
rope or where he was just so huge
Christopher Walken hasn't hosted SNL in
a decade but in his 7 appearances on the
show he's made a mark that few other
hosts could ever hope to not every host
with a distinct personality can fit into
SNL style but others managed to find a
way to work their weirdness right into
the show's framework in walkins case
that's exactly what happened his unique
voice expressive face and ability to be
extremely weird and extremely funny at
the same time suit SNL's writers
perfectly and the result is a series of
classic episodes the Continental is
creepy lothario recurring character
always produces plenty of laughs and one
particular sketch starring Walken as a
record producer introduced an iconic
praise into the world's pop culture
lexicon
guess what I got a fever and the only
prescription is Mach Kappa Paris Hilton
hosted SNL in 2005 when her reality show
The Simple Life and her sex tape scandal
made her particularly infamous it made
sense for SNL to seek her out to pull in
big ratings but the resulting episode
was far from the show's past Hilton's
comedy chops left plenty to be desired
and it turns out that behind the scenes
she was an even bigger headache then
head writer Tina Fey was definitely not
a fan in an interview with Howard Stern
she called Hilton unbelievably dumb and
so proud of how dumb she is she also
noted that the heiress once refused to
leave her dressing room after hearing a
sketch idea revolving around her sex
tape and she would continually offer
pitches that mocked various celebrities
she didn't like check out one of our
newest videos right here Plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]